if I'm Dana White like yeah dude do  whatever you do get better because  remember when he competes he's gonna be  100 healthy so not and there's no  offseason in the UFC which sucks for  them but you don't think the NFL NBA  guys they're coming off these ankle  sprains or whatever it is are taking  [ __ ] to become healthy like their bodies  their business so they're going to do  whatever it takes to get back to full  health by any means necessary and you  guys judging Conor or anybody else  anybody else that's done things after a  horrific injury like that you don't know  what the [ __ ] you're talking about the  stakes are so goddamn High yeah I would  do the exact same thing